breaking the rules right up top here a
question for both of you that you can
chime in on what's something that we see
in this movie that someone out there
might assume is like pure sci-fi
something completely out of the realm of
possibility but in your preparation for
the film you realize that it really is
in the not so distant future for us
i i don't think there's anything in this
film that isn't in the not so distant
future for us i mean i i uh you know
speaking for myself i'm i'm doing a show
about the sacklers right now and and and
oxycontin and the process by which they
arrived at oxycontin and it's
nothing uh
at this point would would shock me yeah
i think uh so i agree i don't think i
don't think it's science fiction i think
everything in this film could be
happening today and likely will happen
at some point soon
yeah if you're exploring the sacklers
right now i imagine your your head is
firmly in that space and anything is
possible which is wildly disturbing
joseph for you i was wondering because i
was reading that paul and rhett
initially wanted to direct the film
themselves so is there anything about
them having that mentality writing the
script that you found helpful when you
stepped in and took those reins
you know i just
i think the script so represents their
what makes them so special and unique uh
that the tone being able to capture
george's
tone from his short story and and
expanded into a feature film you know if
you had read that short story i don't
think there's any way you would ever
think it could be
worthy of a film and they just they
wrote this thing that i didn't put down
i read it cover to cover when i first
got it which is a great sign and it was
just to me
an incredible challenge
as a director and i thought it would be
a really fun challenge for the right
actors to tackle
and just make something totally unique
and different than anything else out
there with that in mind you have one
heck of an ensemble here so is there
ever a moment where one of your cast
members just like completely surprised
you where you went into directing a
scene with a specific vision in mind but
it completely veered and changed course
because of something that they did on
the spot
well you know this is my third film with
miles so you know i just think he's got
incredible range is so talented so i
knew uh he was going to bring that but i
think chris
what he did every day on set to play
this character it's totally different
than anything we've seen him do before
to do it in an american accent to be so
charming and funny and entertaining but
also have this darkness
um and just the complexity of this
almost sociopathic character um to me
was was
uh such a fun thing to see on set every
single day i'm really really excited for
people to see it it's a fun thing to
watch disturbing but quite enjoyable all
right eric for you there's a lot of
challenges on this movie especially
because you did film it at the beginning
of covid so of everything you had a film
for this was there any particular day on
the shooting schedule that had you kind
of like circling it in red and saying
that day in particular we're gonna have
our work cut out for us
i suppose
getting movies made is as you know a
small miracle uh every time you actually
get one going i would say the process by
which
we
willed this into being which took
collective effort of a lot of people
joe and chris and and and the folks at
netflix everybody was
aligned in wanting to make this film
but as you as you said during covid
particularly in the early days of kovid
it was incredibly challenging and so i
suppose that uh you know and very much
in joe's capable hands once we started
shooting
in a lot of ways the hardest part was
behind us obviously there was a
tremendous amount of work to be done but
just the fact that we got there
was
enough of a an accomplishment that
everything else seemed
slightly easier you may have a different
point of view because you're actually
producing yes exactly my job ends once
you know i'm i'll see you at the wrap
party no i uh
never ends i think um
i do think there were moments certainly
scenes that
we worried about
i know there were things that had to
work and and this is not and never was
designed to be an effects show where
you know we would figure it out and post
uh this was in camera this is why joe
was the right person for this job
because it's something that if it's not
there when we shoot it it's not going to
be there so
i i would say this one had its its share
of
god i hope this works this moment that
moment
so um it is you know it's it's been
two years now i think since we shot it
it it was a it was there were a lot of
challenges for sure
well challenges i'm glad you tackled
because the world needs movies and you
guys helped keep the industry afloat
through a really crazy place so
congratulations and it's greatly
appreciated thank you very much